[Musique]
la pompe à cosmo gaulle est arrêté les
shadoks épuisé refuse de pompey mais il
restait le sorcier en ce temps là en
effet sur la planète shadoks il y avait
un sorcier
il s'occupait plus spécialement
d'astrologie et c'était lui qui par
exemple était chargé tous les matins de
faire le soleil se lever
ça lui prenait le temps qu'il fallait
mais tous les jours il y arriver et à
cause de cela les shadoks le respecter
et l'adorait comme tout seul lui le sait
quand même pas mal de temps libre
entre deux il était plombier il détecter
les fuites d'eau et des bouchers les
lavabos il disait aussi qu'il disait
l'avenir dans son robinet magique et le
chef shadoks lui-même venaient le
consulter souvent sur des problèmes de
gouvernement ou des problèmes de
robinets c'est ainsi que prenant la
direction des opérations
le sorcier installe son robinet sur la
peau à cosmo goal est dit que quoi de
sorcier on verrait ce congrès est que le
cos moghol sortirait de son robinet
sortira-t-il sortira t'il pas
[Musique]